Thanks to Google for sponsoring
a portion of today's video.
Fascinating. Truly astonishing…
This… this could rewrite everything we know
about Egyptian society. The world has to know!
Hello Internet! Welcome to Film Theory, the
show that goes on weekly archaeological digs to
look for that buried lore. Now, today we’re doing
something a bit different. We’re taking the script
and throwing it out the window. You see, normally
when we do a lore theory, they all build off of
previous videos in the series like a wobbly Jenga
stack. That way, bit by bit, piece by piece, we
get closer to the truth. And if something’s wrong,
well, we go back and course correct before moving
on from there. But what if someone ELSE has it all
figured out? What if we are so COMPLETELY off base
that that already wobbly stack of lore is also
built on, like…I dunno. rubber band legs…while
an earthquake is going on. I’m talking about bad
theories friends! I mean, it’s not like we’ve ever
had any of THOSE before. But seriously, there’s
always more than one way to analyze a franchise,
and KanePixel’s Backrooms is the perfect
example of this. Now, in case you don’t know,
the Backrooms is a massively popular analog
horror webseries found right here on YouTube,
created by the visual effects artist KanePixels.
It’s all about a creepy alternate dimension of
endless office hallways that people are
“noclipping” into and getting trapped in,
as well as the scientific research company ASYNC
who keeps trying to figure out what the Backrooms
are all about. Right now, our working lore theory
is that the world of the Backrooms is actually
one big simulation. ASYNC’s experiments have
broken part of the “game engine” that’s running
said simulation, thereby allowing people to noclip
into areas with cut content or unused ideas. And,
because they’ve broken it, now everything
is glitched, putting the world in danger.
But you see, ours isn’t the only popular theory
that’s been floating around for this series.
In the fan community, there’s been ANOTHER very
popular solution to what we see throughout these
uploads. See, several popular fan theories
have made a connection between KanePixel’s
Backrooms and Ancient Egyptian mythology.
Yea, you heard that one right! Ancient Egypt:
Complete with mummies and Anubis and the Field
of Reeds. If that sounds wild to you, well,
you’re not alone! It did to me too! On a surface
level, the yellow hallways of the Backrooms don’t
really seem like they’d share all that much of
anything in common with the shifting sands of
Ancient Egypt. And yet, there’s a community of
theorists out there who appear to have found a
surprising number of parallels between the
two. So that's why we're here. To review
their evidence and go further. Give more. And
ultimately render a verdict. Are the Backrooms
secretly connected to Ancient Egypt? Ladies
and gentlemen, strap in! It’s MORTY time!
So, the oldest example I could find
of someone calling out the potential
Backrooms/Egypt connection was this Reddit
thread by u/alexmijowastaken on March 23rd,
2022. Given the flurry of posts in the aftermath
of Kane’s first video though, I may have missed
something earlier, so apologies if I did. Since
that first post, though, a ton of other theorists
have flooded in to analyze the connections. The
most in-depth example is this massive six-page
analysis from u/ZackGardner on the entire
Backrooms storyline. Now, this thread is
LONG, so i’m just going to touch on the highlights
here. First, and most importantly, the name:
KV-31. In the Backrooms, KV-31 is the project
designation that ASYNC gives to their “Low
Proximity Magnetic Distortion System” - aka their
portal into the Backrooms. At first, “KV-31” might
just seem like a couple random letters and numbers
that got slapped together, but it actually shares
its name with a real world location: a Tomb
in Egypt’s Valley of Kings also named KV-31.
Hmmm…interesting, let's dive deeper. Literally.
The topmost shaft of the tomb was discovered all
the way back in October of 1817, but the rest
of the complex remained undiscovered until
about 2010. Then, in January of that year,
archaeologists discovered that the complex
actually went much deeper than first believed.
Now, just on a surface level, that already seems
somwhat similar to the Backrooms, right? Our
world exists on top of an undiscovered tomb,
which remained undisturbed for thousands of
years, exactly how the Backrooms was “underneath”
the real world until ASYNC’s discovery.
Egyptologists were also shocked to discover
that the KV-31 tomb kept going down deeper than
they initially expected. There were hidden layers,
new floors to unearth as you got deeper, exactly
what we see Async uncovering in the Backrooms.
But the connections between the two go beyond
merely the name and the general idea of “secret
tomb go down.” As archeologists worked their
way through the KV-31 tomb, they discovered the
remains of 5 mummies from Egypt’s 18th Dynasty.
And now look at the Backrooms. How many Missing
Persons posters are we shown? 5. And when we
DO happen to find one of those bodies “buried”
in the Backrooms…it appears dehydrated. Dry and
leathery. Kinda like the remains of a mummified
person in an ancient Egyptian tomb. And that’s not
all. The mummies that were found in KV-31 were so
mangled that they were missing limbs and
unidentifiable, just like the victims of the
Bacteria Monster that we see in Kane’s series.
On another note, researchers of KV-31 installed
a metal door over the shaft during the excavation
to prevent any unwelcome intruders from entering
the tomb. This is very similar to how we see ASYNC
erect a metal barrier between their control room
and the Backrooms, preventing people from getting
in while also preventing any undead monsters from
possibly getting OUT. Speaking of doors by
the way, other reddit users have pointed out
that the doors for ASYNC’s portal look awfully
similar to the “false doors” that can be found
in Egyptian tombs. These False Doors were
carvings or paintings that are meant to be
artistic representations of a door that acted as
a threshold between the worlds for the living and
the dead. These were meant to be doors through
which the spirits of the dead could pass from
the Earth to the Afterlife. Given how deadly
the Backrooms have proven so far for anyone
who noclips in, let’s just say demand would be
high for anything helping guide dead spirits.
In fact, the entire Backrooms idea bears a
striking resemblance to the Egyptian concept
of the Duat, or the Egyptian afterlife. According
to Egyptologist John H. Taylor, the content of the
Duat drew directly from what the Egyptians knew
in their day-to-day life: realistic features like
rivers, fields, caverns, and islands, while
also incorporating more fantastical imagery
like lakes of fire, turquoise trees, and walls of
iron. And while the Backrooms isn’t drawing from
natural features like rivers and caverns, it IS
drawing from everyday mundane things that we’re
all familiar with: ugly wallpaper, fluorescent
lights, wet carpeting. It also takes the normal,
and makes it ABnormal, kinda like the Field of
Reeds. And while, no, we haven’t yet seen anything
as outright fantastical as a lake of fire, we
HAVE seen farmhouses hidden inside the walls,
giant chairs, and homes full of backwards
road signs, all things that we’re used to
seeing in our day-to-day lives, but combined with
other ideas that they shouldn’t be mixed with.
So, that’s pretty much the main points of the
fan-created “Backrooms is actually Egypt” theory.
What's my take on it? Well, before we get to that,
let’s pause for a moment to thank our sponsor for
this portion of today's video: Google. Have you
noticed that Google recently added all these
little badges across Search, Maps, and Shopping
to let you know at a glance that you’re supporting
diversely owned local businesses? ‘Cause
honestly, If I hadn't been sponsored by them,
I wouldn’t have. And you know what? I love
it. I’m so glad that they’ve partnered with
me to tell you about this because I think it’s
an awesome new tool that more people should be
aware of. Google has always been about sorting
the world’s information, right? Well, these new
badges empower YOU with the information you need
to support businesses that fit with your unique
set of values. Suddenly: identifying Women-,
Black-, Latino-, and Veteran-owned businesses
is super simple, it’s literally at a glance
And this is just the beginning of how Google
plans to support local communities. They’ve also
made it easy for businesses on Google Search,
Maps, and Shopping to mark themselves as safe
for people all across the LGBTQ spectrum. That
means that if you’re looking for a gender-neutral
bathroom, a Transgender-friendly bar, or you just
want to support LGBTQ-friendly businesses, you
can quickly identify those places. Our team is
incredibly diverse. Even though all you tend to
see is me in front of the camera, we have people
from an entire spectrum of different backgrounds.
As a result, we see firsthand how important this
push towards inclusion is. Everyone deserves a
place where they are accepted, where they can be
themselves. Personally, I want to live in a world
that’s made for everyone, and features like this
are a step in that direction. Hopefully one day,
we’ll get to a place in society where labels like
this aren’t necessary and everyone is just like
“woo, let’s all succeed together”. But until then,
Google is doing its best to make that information
as accessible as possible. If you want to find out
more about how Google is helping build
that world, where everyone is welcome
and everyone belongs, you can find out more at
Belonging.Google.com. Thanks again to Google for
sponsoring that portion of this video, and
now let’s Noclip back into the Backrooms.
Having laid out all the evidence…what do you
think? Seriously. Let me know down in the
comments. I’d love to have your thoughts on this
theory, ‘cause here’s the way I see it – I’m not
buying it. I love a good off-the-wall theory, and
there have been plenty of times where I’ve been
known to stretch REAL hard to get some evidence.
But looking at the whole Egypt connection thing;
what’s here is circumstantial at best, and even
worse, doesn’t really add up to all that much.
Let’s start here with the biggie, the point to me
that’s the most compelling: The name, KV-31. Yes,
the fact that the ASYNC project name and this tomb
in Egypt line up is a fascinating coincidence,
but we just don’t have enough evidence to
call it anything beyond that. First of all,
KV-31 is an entirely unremarkable tomb. It’s not
very big like the seemingly endless Backrooms
and it didn’t contribute anything significant
to Egyptian archaeology. But more importantly,
there are HUNDREDS of tombs all around Egypt. It’s
easy to hear a phrase like “Ancient Egyptian Tomb”
and think something grand and mysterious like the
pyramids, but in reality, they were just, like,
fancy basements for burials. When I visited Egypt
ten years ago, I went to a few that were literally
in the middle of some guy’s backyard. No joke.
We in the West have this mystique and allure
attached to Egyptian tombs, but they’re more
common than the media would have you believe.
Going back to KV-31. The “KV” stands for Valley
of the Kings, it’s on the West Bank of the Nile
right across from Luxor. And in this one area
alone, there are roughly 63 numbered tombs…KV-01
all the way through KV-63. If Kane had picked
ANY KV number between 1 and 63, this exact same
argument could have been made. It seems far more
likely to me that Kane either came up with a cool,
sci-fi sounding collection of letters and numbers
that just so happened to coincide with an obscure
dig site in Egypt. OR he knew about the numbering
system inside the Valley of the Kings, thought it
sounded cool, and used it for Async’s project
name with little thought beyond that. Trust me,
guys. I get it. I’ve been there. I see a weird
world-building detail like that in a franchise
that I love and want to theorize about, and so
I try to reverse engineer it. I Search KV-31
to see what comes up and BOOM! First result:
Egyptian tomb. From there, I would try to look
for what else I can add to the theory…what other
connections I could make that could be added to
that stack of Jenga blocks. I get why people would
want to go down this rabbit hole cause I would do
the exact same thing. So, let’s keep going to get
a sense of how stable the rest of the evidence is.
Let’s look at the so-called connections between
all the doors, shall we? The archaeologists in
charge of excavating KV-31 sealed the tomb off
using a metal door, just like ASYNC seals off
their entrance to the Backrooms using a metal
door. Sure, that a connection of sorts… but
probably doesn’t mean all that much of anything.
It’s far more likely that metal doors were chosen
in both circumstances because they’re common
building materials that provide strong protection.
That is just what happens when you’re trying
to build a secure door in modern times. And the
idea that ASYNC’s portal looks like an Egyptian
False Door? I mean… They’re both multi-tiered,
rectangular entranceways, but that’s
because…they’re doors. More importantly,
though, the theorists that are drawing the
connection here overlook a major point – the
FALSE part of the Egyptian FALSE door. They’re
fake. They were etchings used to simulate
REAL doors. Kane’s design for the Backrooms door,
meanwhile, appears to be entirely functional.
There’s the main entryway! And it’s surrounded
by cabinets that appear to have the necessary
wires and electronics to make the main door
function. This comparison also ignores that
False Door carvings were typically taller and
thinner, while Kane’s design is short and squat.
As for the five mummies found within the KV-31
tomb compared to the five missing people that we
see called out in Kane’s series? That right there
on the surface, seems like it’d be a really solid
piece of evidence, until of course, you do the
research for yourself. There aren’t just 5 missing
people that are called out in Kane’s series. There
are actually 6! 6 posters with 6 different people
shown in the video Missing Persons, as you can see
right here. It’s shown for a brief moment before
the entire scene fades into this line graph. But
what about the bodies that were mangled down there
in KV-31? Sadly, if you look into WHY they were
so damaged, things fall apart even further. See,
the tomb had been thoroughly robbed throughout its
history, with damage attributed to both ancient
robbers looking for valuables and more modern
robbers stealing the body parts of mummies to
sell to tourists; Humans are great. If KV-31
was really meant to connect to the Backrooms,
that would imply that other people had been
exploring the hallways before ASYNC opened the
portal. This graph that we see here in “Missing
Persons” explicitly makes it clear that cases for
missing people skyrockets after ASYNC makes
contact with the Backrooms. It's only after
they break that seal, that noclipping begins.
And finally, we get to the quote-unquote “Evidence
point” about the Backrooms taking modern mundane
places and twisting them into something uncanny,
just like the Duat afterlife. And to that I
say…Really? Y…you think that’s evidence? That
is just storytelling technique 101. You
know who else found everyday objects and
then twisted them into something uncanny? The
Brave Little Toaster. Honey I Shrunk the Kids.
Blues Clues. And something tells me that
I’m not getting away with a Backrooms
is Secretly the sequel to Blues Clues theory.
So, what happened here? Why did so many theorists
see ASYNC’s project designation KV-31 and work
so hard to connect it with the KV31 tomb? Well,
I don’t blame them for doing so. Like
I’ve said throughout this Theory,
it’s a fascinating coincidence, and this amazing
community of Theorists was doing their best to
try and put the pieces together. Just to prove
my point here: before deciding whether or not
I thought the connections between Egypt
and the Backrooms was even intentional,
I did a ton of additional research to see if I
could find anything else that might strengthen
this entire theory. Dots that no one else had
connected yet. And if I looked hard enough,
yeah, the dots were there, but just like
everything we’ve already talked about,
they were just stretched out of the bounds
of reason. For example, one could say that
the backrooms wallpaper texture bears a passing
resemblance to a pattern of reeds, potentially
another connection to the Duat. But that doesn’t
make a ton of sense because the Field of Reeds is
the paradise afterlife for Egyptians, rather than
the endless maze-like hell that is the Backrooms.
See, when there’s a mystery where something
connects in an interesting or unusual way, humans
like to seek answers. Our brains are hardwired
to find explanations for the unexplained,
even if there aren’t any answers. This is
a phenomenon called pareidolia. It means
that people have a tendency to impose meaningful
interpretation onto random data, finding patterns
where there aren’t any. Have you ever looked up at
the clouds and seen a face or shape within them?
Or seen those pictures of houses that look like
people that occasionally go viral? That’s possible
because of pareidolia. Your brain is telling you
that that cloud looks like a dog or that house
is giving you a creepy side eye, not because they
actually are but because it's human nature to see
patterns within the noise. And that’s what
I think happened with KV-31, and this whole
nothing burger of ancient Egyptian connections.
A final example here: I thought that we might be
able to connect the Bacteria Monsters to Egyptian
tombs, specifically as some sort of manifestation
of the Curse of the Pharaohs. This was an alleged
curse “cast” upon anyone who broke into an
Egyptian tomb. It became popular folklore after
researchers mysteriously died in the aftermath
of opening King Tut's tomb. Though there were
many speculated causes, one of the most popular
theories was that there was some sort of ancient
bacteria or pathogen that was dormant in the tomb
that was unleashed by opening it. The curse had
a MASSIVE impact on popular culture at the time.
It's also worth mentioning that more recently, a
pool of black goo was discovered in a 3000 year
old sarcophagus. I mean, really! That has to
be a clear connection to the Bacteria monster,
right? But, here’s the thing… There's no
evidence or scientific backing that the “curse”
ever existed at all, let alone that it was caused
by Bacteria. Instead, all of the deaths can be
attributed to more natural causes, like blood
poisoning from a mosquito bite. And that black
goo in the sarcophagus? Apparently, it was just a
mixture of stuff used as an adhesive to keep the
sarcophagi sealed, not anything harmful to humans.
Gotta admit, I really tried to find a genuine
connection here, because the idea that there
was an additional layer to the Backrooms,
that it was hiding some historical epic just
beneath its surface of ugly yellow wallpaper.
It’s genuinely awesome; and Egypt is always cool
to talk about. But, everything the community
pointed out can easily be dismissed or debunked,
to the point that I just don’t think that there’s
a whole lot there. The ancient Egyptian
connections were interesting coincidences…
but that’s all wound up being, Loyal Theorists.
Coincidences. Film coincidences. Aaaaand cut.